الى قاعده ينجرلك في اضنه تحديدا شرق اضنه
حيث ينضم الينا مراسل الجزيره المعتز بلا
حسن معتز بالله مرحبا بك معنا اذا الصوره
حيث انت حيث تصل وربما تتوزع مجموعات
المساعدات الى المناطق المتضرره اجمل لنا
الصوره من حيث استقبال تركيا وطريقه
ادارتها ايضا لهذه المساعدات
نحن هنا في قاعده هذه القاعده الجويه
التركيه الشهيره هذه القاعده تحولت في
الايام التي تلت الزلزال الى خليه نحل
حقيقيه دعني اريك هنا في الصوره هذه
المساعدات التي تاتي من المدن التركيه
الاخرى التي وعلى راسها انقر اسطنبول
ازمير ترسل مساعدات الى هنا وليس فقط من
هذه المدن من كل دول العالم المساعدات
التي من كل دول العالم هي تصب في هذه
القاعده هنا ومن ثم يتم نقل هذه المواد
والمساعدات سواء عبر الشاحنات الى المناطق
المتضرره
وعبر ايضا المروحيات
وانواع الاخرى من الطائرات الى المناطق
التي لا يمكن للشاحنات الوصول اليها
المروحيات هي تطير في المناطق الجبليه
ربما توصل للمساعدات الى المناطق الجبليه
هذه المساعدات هنا ربما يمكن ان
هذه القاعده طبعا كنا في ان
جر كما ذكرت على الاقل 60 الى 70 مروحيه
طارت وسطين هذا الرقم وسطي طبعا طارت خلال
الايام الماضيه من اجل نقل هذه المساعدات
الى
الجبليه الناهيه حيث لا يمكن ربما
للسيارات العاديه الوصول في ذلك المكان
هناك نشاهد الخيم المواد الاخرى كلها جمعت
في هذا المكان الطائره التي تاتي تاتي الى
هذا المكان ليتم تحميلها ومن ثم يتم نقل
هذه
المساعدات القادمه من دول العالم ومن
المدن التركيه الاخرى الى مناطق الاحتياج
تحدثت مع المسؤول هنا في القاعده واكدوا
ان هناك عمل دائم على مدى الساعات الاربعه
والعشرين لايصال هذه المساعدات الى
محتاجيها طبعا ما تنقله المروحيات التركيه
من هذه القاعده ليس فقط المساعدات اخبرني
احد الاشخاص في القاعده انه تم ايضا نقل
حتى الكلاب البوليسيه التي كانت تبحث بين
الانقاض كل ما من شانه ان يفيد في عمليات
الانقاذ وان يفيد في عمليات مساعده الناس
المتضررين في المنطقه النائيه كل ذلك تم
نقله من هذه القاعده الرئيسيه وطبعا
كميات المساعدات التي نراها هنا في هذا
المكان هي كميات كبيره جدا يتم تنسيق هذه
المساعدات من قبل الموظفين الموجودين هنا
وفرز هذه المساعدات الى انواع متعدده بعد
فرز هذه المساعدات تنقل كل مساعده الى
المنطقه التي تحتاجها مثال اذا كان هناك
حاجه لخيام فان هذه الخيام تنقل عبر
المروحيات اضافه الى المساعدات الغذائيه
اذا كان هناك حاجه لنقل موظفي المؤسسات
التركيه الاخرى الذين لهم علاقه بالانقاذ
ايضا يمكن نقل هؤلاء الى هناك ليس فقط
الطيران او المروحيات التركيه هناك
مروحيات ايضا من بلدان اخرى هناك مروحيات
من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هناك
مروحيات من قطر كل ذلك هو في سياق جهد
متكامل من اجل انقاذ ودعم المتضررين من
الزلزال هذا الزلزال الكبير الذي ضرب
اكثر من عشر محافظات تركيا وهي بحسب
القرار الذي صدر عن الرئيس التركي مؤخرا
بات عددها احد عشر باضافه محافظه الى هنا
في هذه في هذا المكان
كما نشاهد ربما الحركه مستمره ليلا نهارا
من اجل فرز المساعدات ونقلها الوضع في
قاعده بحسب المسؤولين الذين تحدثنا اليهم
هو وضع استنفار اقصى طبعا المناطق الجبليه
التي يتم النقل لها المروحيه الواحده
تنتقل بين عده مناطق جبليه وليس شرطا ان
تقف في مكان واحد ايضا احدى المهمات التي
تقوم بها المروحيات هنا هي موضوع نقل
المصابين للمشفى ساحاول الاقتراب ايضا
قليلا من هذا المكان المكان الذي توجد فيه
المساعدات ربما نلقي نظره عن قرب لكن دون
ان نعيق حركه العمل هنا
صح ربما
الصوره من اعلى قد تريكم حجم المساحه او
حجم المساعدات الموجوده في هذا المكان
هناك شاحنات كثيره لم تفرغ بعد وهناك
شاحنات اخرى تنتظر ان يتم
تعبئتها ونقلها طبعا الطائرات لا تهدا هنا
حاليا المروحيات هي في الطريق طريق العوده
الى القاعده بحسب ما اخبرنا المسؤولون
الزلزال اثر بشكل مباشر على مساحه كبيره
وبالتالي هناك حاجه لنقل كل هذه المعدات
الى
المناطق المنكوبه طبعا هذه القاعده هي
تنسق معظم الرحلات الجويه التي تنتقل او
تنقل المساعدات وهي جزء كما اخبرنا
المسؤولون هنا من جهود الجيش التركي
لاغاثه المنكوبين في المناطق المتضرره من
الزلزال والذين هم في امس الحاجه لها وبلا
شك في انتظار ان تصلهم باسرع وقت اشكرك
معتز بالله حسن من قاعده انجر ليك على كل
هذه المعلومات يعني